okay so this is going to be a survey on
approximate counting and it's a boot
camp it's supposed to be for the people
who don't already know it and so
actually what I hope is that anybody who
doesn't know it will feel free to
interrupt me all the time with questions
because that's the purpose if you
already know it of course you already
know it and you're not going to learn
anything and that's how it goes I'm
bored I what I want to do is to kind of
give you there are lot of results that
we think of as folklore you know this
problem is this hard this problem is
that hard we just have some working
knowledge and I wanted to share that
just with the people who aren't in this
little game so what I want to start
doing I want to start by um approximate
counting is actually a big topic and so
I'm gonna tell you've only a very small
part of it and I thought I'd first
orient you with how does it fit in to
what you're going to hear in the rest of
this webcam which is quite a lot so I'm
going to talk about the relative
complexity of approximate counting
problems and in particular I'm going to
tell you about this intermediate problem
counting independent sets and bipartite
graphs which surprisingly just comes
back and back and seems to have some
real importance um one of our main
techniques for approximate counting
algorithms is markov chain monte carlo
and this is absolutely a key in the area
but i'm not going to tell you anything
about it because ivana and my entire are
actually going to give two surveys just
about that well I'm on the positive
techniques the other excellent technique
that we have for approximate counting is
correlation decay and I'm gonna say all
those nothing about that because your
tongue is going to tell us about that
and I think about the hardness that
comes from phase transitions one of the
key application areas of approximate
counting and one of the place in which
we really get results is constraint
satisfaction which any sort of mentioned
and Dave's going to be talking about
that so what I'm trying to do is avoid
all that and tell you everything else
that gives you
oh okay and because it's a survey and I
really just want to tell you what we
know i'm not gonna spend much time on
whose idea was that and so I've just
listed a bunch of names here and these
people deserve loads of credit but I may
not get time to point out which thing
okay running example in the talk is
going to be the pots model if anybody is
here from physics you might wonder why i
present it in a slightly strange way and
there is a reason for it which we'll see
later ok so the pots model it's a spin
model Jim you talk to us a little bit
about spin models oh yeah okay so we're
going to have a set of spins q spins and
the pods model is the model of spins on
a graph so the vertices of the graph
will be assigned spins much as in
Jenny's world but the spins of giving
interact and we're going to have some
interactions drinks that tells you about
the interaction of the spins and we're
going to be interested in the partition
function so I want to do this slowly
because everything in counting and
approximate counting is essentially
about computing these partition
functions so what is the partition
function well we've got some parameters
the number of spins and how do they
interact we'd like to consider
configurations and a configuration is
just an assignment of spins to the
vertices a configuration has a weight
what is the weight well it's just the
product over all the edges of what well
if two vertices next to each other have
the same spin sorry about that I that's
going to annoy us I can turn the Wi-Fi
off sorry
others it'll do it every five minutes
okay so if two things have the same way
than the way this 1 plus gamma and if
they are two vertices of the same film
than the waiters 11 gamma if they have
different spins then it's Delta this
zero so the way this one ok so we're
summing over all assignments as fans
product owner alleges 1 plus gamma is
the two spoons of the set ok ok so the
easing model as the special case 1 q is
equal to 2 there are only two spin 0 and
1 and the model said to be ferromagnetic
if the weight is more when the two
spoons are the same so that corresponds
to the interaction being greater than
zero ok
if we check out to be minus 1 then this
would count the proper color q cones of
the graph because when delta when these
are the same we would get one x minus
one so we get a zero so it doesn't count
but if they're different then we just
get white one so the whole thing would
add up to the number of q colorings all
right now um actually before I go on is
that I will just keep coming back to
this model it's going to be an example
of everything maybe you actually already
know it at anything unclear ok so now
under say a few things about how does
this fit into commutation chemical but
Jimmy already told you is that
computational counting is actually about
computing sums of products so this is a
sort of perfect example of that and the
next thing that I want to kind of point
out is that this is essentially a number
piecing so those of you that are
interested in complexity theory if if
gamma for a natural number then
obviously you could expand this as paths
of a computation which either accept or
reject with is appropriate a number of
branches so this thing would be in
number P and as long as gamma is
rational you can sort of divide it out
so you get something that's a sin
each of the number three so we're going
to be looking in this talk at counting
problems inside number of people okay so
obviously there are more extreme things
but that's not what we're going to do
and just a little look ahead later we'll
let these interactions depend on the
edge so yeah it just might have
different strengths to which they can
deliver their spins are different with
the same so we'll come back to that ok
now this talk is supposed to be about
approximate counting so I thought to
tell you what the goal is for
approximate counting so we're interested
in computing these partition functions
we're very interested in how they are
hard there to be exactly but that's for
other talks and this chocolate want to
talk about computing them approximately
okay so in order to talk about that we
have to say what do we mean by
approximation and some of you might be
used to optimization where we can talk
about you know you can get within one
point one of the answer but not within
1.0 19 and very precise things and so a
little little spin a little while
showing you why an approximate counting
none of this at least at this time then
of this precision really arises okay so
the typical measure of success for
approximate [ __ ] is the other press
and I'm sure most of you have seen it
but I'm going to go ahead and tell the
rest of you what it is so a fully
polynomial is a randomized approximation
scheme for computing the value of the
function f just takes an instance like
maybe the graph if the problem is the
pots model but also as inputs of a pile
on that tells you how accurately do you
want to approximate this thing and the
goal is to compute a rational number
which is very close to the desired
quantity f of X I you that partition
function
very close means that given a Cylon you
get within roughly 1 plus or minus
epsilon and here's why we're interested
in a randomized approximation scheme so
we allow that the algorithm to fail with
some small probability ok so so the goal
is you input an instance for example the
graph you input a Cylon that says how
close do you want to be the partition
function a good algorithm will with high
probability give you a number that's
within your desired closeness all right
now obviously such an approximation
algorithm is really I mean it's very
good because it can get as close as you
like you know you don't um one more
thing let's talk about the running time
the running time of the algorithm should
of course be polynomial the input size
but typically we allow it to be also
polynomial in one over epsilon so as you
demand more and more accuracy by making
up seven small you're allowed more time
but only polynomial is so ok so that's
an F press and if prize is an algorithm
that satisfies that property okay so
that's a very strong form of
approximation and you might wonder why
do we desire such a strong thing isn't
it good enough to get within a factor of
two or something and the answer to that
is that if you don't have an if press
then for partition functions actually
you can't even get close to the right
answer so typically with partition
functions either you get an F press or
you just turn is approximately go so let
me let me tell you why that's true so
suppose we have a graph G and we wanted
to evaluate the partition function what
I could do is I could take K disjoint
copies of G just flop on there ok
coffees now if I do that the partition
function of the pots model on this joint
thing composed of cake copies
is just the product right at about the
spins on each copy multiplied together
so suppose that I had an algorithm that
approximated the pots partition function
within some constant maybe within a
factor of K but if I wanted an
enterprise all I would do is make a big
enough corresponding to my designer of
Cylon and then take the case route and I
would get it okay so this is I mean at
the end of proclamation with the
polynomial factor would be just as good
a meaningful notion would be to
approximate the log partition function
yeah and on exactly ok so the question
was about what about approximating the
log partition function and I will
mention that um we know less about that
and it's a very meaningful thing and I
will get there okay so but for right now
we're just trying to evacuate the
partition function itself okay so for
the partition function where you should
keep in mind is either we've got an F
prize or else you just can't approximate
at all so what'd you think well around a
nice approximation and let's pick of all
too many secrets okay excellent so
there's another question which is why do
I speak about randomized approximation
what about deterministic and the answer
is actually that once upon a time all of
our algorithms were randomized that's
not even true anymore and if you don't
like randomization then just put F PTAs
in there and not much is going to change
nothing i'm going to really talk about
in this talk is going to be very
important about randomness okay and
anyway RP is probably pee anyway that's
not okay okay now the next thing I want
to address is how hard is it to
approximate these problems how hard can
it be because we think of counting is
really really hard right we've got the
polynomial hierarchy and at the top of
that we got number p that's a really
hard thing approximate counting is
different it's really only ever NP hard
so I want to talk this is very very old
result but I think maybe people upset
the area
so I want to just talk about this so how
hard can it be to f prize a problem
another fee well it can obviously be
np-hard because if you f press the
number of satisfying assignments you can
definitely tell if there's a satisfying
assignment so surely it can be np-hard
but it can't be really any harder than
that okay um so fabula 80s valiant
vazirani introduced this bisection
technique which showed that you can
approximate the number of satisfying
assignments of a boolean formula just
with an Oracle for the decision problem
and I don't want to probably take too
much time on this but let me just give
you the rough idea and good this is a
randomized idea and but you basically
just reduce the size of the solution
space by unity time by for example you
know adding a constraint maybe we should
just think about it the same dis
variables to a false anyway you keep
doing that check whether you got a
satisfying assignment then multiply up
so I don't want to do that in much
detail but I do want you to realize that
approximating it's not like number p
it's like anything okay so that's that's
where we live so approximately problems
to take problems in number p but getting
an F press can be np-hard not not worse
okay now if we had an empress for a
number sat we would actually have an
empress for every problem in number P
and that's because if you go way back to
cooks theorem its parsimonious which
means there's a one-to-one by jection
between accepting computations of the
Turing machine and satisfying
assignments so f housing everything in
number P is only Hindi okay what do you
buy all the NP hard I just mean that as
a person number behind so we're going to
be interested in polynomial time but I'm
just within complexity theory we're not
way up in the because the exact counting
is really hard right it's harder than
everything in the bulb in the hierarchy
and so the point is just we're not up
there where we're down on planet earth
or something yeah okay so what I'm going
to talk to you about this time then is
looking at counting problems within
number P and trying to figure out how do
they compare which are the hardest ones
which is an easy one so we actually know
how to F prize other ones we don't know
how to f prize but we understand their
relative complexity okay so for that we
need a notion of reduction between
approximate counting problems and I just
want to apologize to peel the agenda see
because we stole the word for this an AP
reduction already had a meaning in
optimization and we we didn't know about
people whose paper but anyway if you're
aware of AP reductions as everybody uses
them in optimization then the point I
just want to make is that something else
ok so don't think of Africa an
approximation preserving reduction for
approximate canting let me first give
you the
fine what should it be it should be a
reduction from one problem to another so
that if you have f prize for this one
you'd get an F prize for that one that's
obviously what you want but of course if
you're really going to define it
formally you have to say and what if you
didn't have an F prize here so the
definition is kind of their many choices
and this definition is one of them it's
designed to be very liberal with what
constitutes a reduction okay so what is
a reduction from one counting problem f2
accounting problem g well it's just a
randomized algorithm for F that uses an
Oracle 4G how does it use the Oracle
Fuji well it starts with an input into F
and some approximation goal it makes
some Oracle calls to the counting
problem g and the technical details are
not very important but we obviously
can't demand absurd accuracy from the
Oracle and then it just has the property
that if you had a randomized
approximation for skip g as the Oracle
then you would get one for chef ok and
at the runtime of your algorithm should
be sensible it should be polynomial and
eczema inverse of it Thailand ok now the
class of if possible problems is closed
under there so what will now going to do
is use this notion of reduction to talk
about the relative difficulty of
approximate counting problems any you
don't really need to know the
technically goes as long as you as long
as you accept that the reduction is
whatever it should be to make sense
at it now once we define such the
introductions between problems for
approximate counting well will we love
to do while Jenny already told us the
goal is dichotomies what we really would
love to do is to understand these are
the problems we can approximate these
are the ones we cannot approximate end
of story that's our goal but that is
impossible so um we would love to have a
dichotomy that says these problems are
if possible they're all is reducible
everything else they're all introduced
into reducible but not approximate but
as you might guess there's a analog of
Ladner's theorem that says now that the
truth won't be left so in 2010 Magnus
Borda [ __ ] prove the following thing so
far as I have a number problem hi and it
doesn't have an enterprise then there's
another moment in broken pipe right but
also has my left breast but pie doesn't
reduce to PI primed okay so if you
iterate this you'll get an infant in
hierarchy of problems with no F press
that don't reduce to each other okay so
so there's no hope of such a beautiful
thing as just as I cottony for number P
we would love it but we know we can't
okay
no it turns out however that we have
found big classes of problems in number
P that are into reducible with respect
to approximation preserving reduction so
that's what I'm going to tell you about
next okay so this is the word Martin
related to an introduction it just turns
out that there are three classes of
inserted into reducible problems so f
present problems obviously they're all
introduced balu cares um problems that
are in the art to approximate those are
into reducible with accounting
satisfying assignments that's not a big
surprise but it turns out an approximate
counting that there's a third class of
introduced it'll problems that kind of
seems to have intermediate complexity
and what I'm gonna hope to do during
this truck is give you a feel for these
problems and how they may be differ from
computing satisfying assignments and
maybe why it is that they all feel same
um so key problem in this class is abyss
which is counting independent sets and
bipartite graphs so if you wanted to
approximate independent sets in any old
graphs that'll turn out we'll see to be
a hard problem at so that said the
complete its introduces sad but counting
independent censured by photographs well
if you want to do it exactly it's
definitely number of incomplete that was
one of those diagrams original problems
but in terms of approximation well we
don't believe there's an F press we
don't really believe it's at the same
difficulty of sad either so it seems to
be some intermediate complexity class
and I'll be filling in the details
that over this talk okay but before I do
that let me point out another impossible
goal after we know about this what we
might have wished is to split number
peek into a trichotomy a frazzle
problems problems that are the same as
this problems that are the same as SAT
but unfortunately border [ __ ] result
already tells us that this is already
hopeless still because let's apply his
result to base if there's no f president
yes then there's a problem hi which
doesn't have an empress and this doesn't
reduce to it so we get an infinite
hierarchy below this ok so the truth
cannot be confined to these three
complexity classes and what I want to
say and I don't know quite how far I'll
get in this but an interesting thing is
we know that you just we can't just have
a trichotomy we can't have ever has
evolved is that because if this was
different from enterprise we get this
hierarchy below we don't have any
candidates for problem sitting below
this I got loads of problems which I'll
probably tell you about that may sit
above this and in between miss and SATA
that loads the result was like that
things that we only know it is hard but
they might be harder we don't have any
candidates for this even though we know
for Magnus's results of this is where
the infant of hierarchy really would
live so that's that's a little strange
and I'll probably go back to that you've
been saying up up and below but they're
actually possible
compal this is possibly uncomfortable
well okay so one thing we know is that
and I'm only talking about within number
p or within FP to the number P so we
certainly know that everything reduces
to sat because of cooks they're being
parsimonious so that everything is a be
reducible to sat maybe I don't say that
in a minute so that's as hard as it gets
so so it's a good question why do I say
above and below and that's because this
is as hard as you can be to approximate
with it number people hold up a bit long
right and so the problems that are
introduced the bull was that those are
the hardest problems to an F prize
within number P because anything a
number P will reduce to those above the
middle part
right so this is the writer right there
may be all sorts of structure we don't
know about this is a this is a hierarchy
but there may be all sorts of other
rubbish in there they're going to be an
infinite number maybe what June you
saying is that for all we know there are
infinitely many classes all over the
place between business at that could be
I don't know so just to say that the
Ladner's theorem can be extended in such
a way they argued a degree structure
inside and out decided yes and I so
that's right and magnets this thing is
maybe not quite I don't know whether
that question has been asked but but
what we do get here is a hierarchy but
there may be loads of other stuff and
then maybe yeah okay but before we do
any of that I want to back up and show
you places where there are trichotomy
because sometimes we can I mean Thurston
would be totally useless and all I can
tell you is that we can't use it for
anything but actually the interesting
thing is there are loads of contacts in
approximate canning and date is going to
tell you about even more of them in his
talk we're actually these three classes
are all there is so I wanted to start
out by just giving me some elementary
flavors of that so why are these three
classes important because in many cases
that's all ages so let's start with
graph homomorphisms and I Jamie
mentioned this but I think he didn't
define it um because he could use it so
i will now do that so what is a hotly
probably not but so let's do what is a
homomorphism from a graph g to a graph H
well it's a map for the vertices of G to
the vertices of H which preserves edges
so every edge of G has been up to an
edge of it non edges we don't care ok so
hummel morphisms to this H so this is a
graph of two vertices at one self loop
in an edge the corresponding independent
sets because I could label this one in
and that one out now if I take a
homomorphism from G to this graph I'm
labeling the vertices of G in and out
but edges of G can't go to in n so it's
an independent set homomorphisms from G
to this graph are three colorings of G
because I'm mapping the vertices of G
two colors one two three but edges of G
have to go to edges so I can have one
too but I can't have 11 ok so the morph
is a problem kept a counting problem is
given a fixed H how many homomorphisms
are there from an input G change and
that depends on h which is a parameters
is that all right so there's lots of
work on counting homomorphisms exactly
which will think I think we'll see but
what I'm doing in this pictures I've
shown you a picture of all three vertex
connected H's and colored them to tell
you about how difficult approximate
counting is for these so um so this here
this three vertex graph hair colored
green it's very easy to jump
homomorphisms 4g to this probably while
i was bubbling around saying that you
figured out the answer if i have an end
vertex graph g and i wanted to count
homomorphisms to this graph then the
answer would be three to the end yeah
because I can take the vertices of G and
map them to any of these things and
everything's an edge so there are no
constraints similarly this guy
it's trivial it's trivial to count
homomorphisms from g in EG to this graph
because if g is but not bipartite if it
has an odd cycle i'm doomed because
where would it go but if Jesus bipartite
then all I have to do is look at the
left and right of G and say well maybe
the left goes there and the right goes
there so it's 2 to the number of
vertices on the right or the opposite
and add them up now what dire ingredient
proved ages ago is that for exact
counting these two are the only easy
things so if you want to exactly count
homomorphisms then if you have a clip
with loops or a complete bipartite graph
yeah trivial but what they managed to
show is that for any other fixed HSN
tremont it'll be hard now I want to go
back to just three vertex h and this is
a trichotomy for the for the approximate
counting so that i'm going to show you i
hope you can see the colors canyon yeah
okay so the next red i want to talk
about this red one so i already
mentioned that homomorphisms to this
thing are three colorings because color
one color to color three but it just
can't be between colors the same because
there's no self loops so you would see
immediately counting three koel in a
minute anyway we'll say counting three
colorings is as hard as numbers-- at
approximately it's one of our hardest
problems and indeed all these red guys
are in the top category they're all is
hard to approximately countess
satisfying assignments this little blue
guy there
is a h which is sometimes called the wit
of rawlinson model but i don't think it
really cares about this model but anyway
um it's actually equivalent to piss so
if you wanted to count homomorphism
story vertex graphs the truth is there's
nothing else there's a practical and
deep exactly computable there's this
other SAT and that's all there is okay
now sadly no known trichotomy for all
age so its lucky I just tried putting
three vertex H on the slide because if I
gun to four vertices already we'd have
open problems and i think i might spoil
my barter but just drying you one of
them because it's fun except for I can't
draw I feel kind of surprising we still
don't know the difficulty of
approximately counting homomorphisms to
that graph so it's very easy to see that
it's as hard as this okay um and maybe
I'll talk about that later I don't know
but anyway we don't know whether it's
harder or not so that's that's a
candidate for something that may be
harder maybe between this is that we
just don't know okay but um before I
move on to that I want to give you some
more places where we do have tricot amis
and so in order to do that I want to
make the problem both harder and easier
so what I'm going to do is a little bit
similar to introducing external fields
and spin models but once I do that in
order to get a complete result because
we don't know a complete result here
we're going to have to stop talking
about all graphs H and even just go to
trees and weirdly that truth is even
complicated for trees once you add
fields so I want to do that next so I
want to talk about counting weight on
the wharf isms the weights will come as
no surprise that we start
potts model and gifts and by the way the
point of doing this is that I'm going to
come back to the pots model so if you
think that you don't care about comes in
from of morphisms then hang on for a
minute or two and then i'm going to show
you that the pots model is exactly an
example of this so doesn't it okay but I
want to do then is we're going to
introduce a weighting function and what
a way to function is going to do it may
be easier to show in the picture is I'm
gonna introduce weights to the vertices
of H like maybe if a vertex of Jake it's
this color this won't get map to this
vertex i'll give you white one maybe
this vertex way to this vertex wait half
a weight function just is such a set of
weights and we can happen to those for
every vertex of g ok so white function
assigns a non-negative rational way to
each vertex of h and all let's suppose
that we have such a waiting for every
vertex EG then the partition function
that I want to consider the input is the
graph G and these weighting functions
and then I want to sum over
homomorphisms from g2h the product of
the weights ok so it's just a weighted
homomorphism problem make sense so I'm
just summing over all homomorphisms
what's the weight of a homomorphism just
for every vertex V of G just take the
weight of whatever span of god what you
look at all those increases ok so
interesting question he asks whether
were allowed loops and the convention
for reasons that comment Charlie this
made up a long time it goes we normally
do allow them in H and we don't allow
them in G and we can always change that
it's not very important but that is the
convention
that's how I'll presented here okay okay
now can you see the colors that might
have to keep asking about it anyway if
you come to the colors this bit is green
and then there's a blue area and then
there's a red area okay so what I want
to show you is that if you wanted to
look at approximately coming weighted
homomorphisms to trees this is another
situation where we do actually have a
trichotomy and the track of them is
actually really simple so if h is the
start you know just a vertex whip
connected to a bunch of edges like that
one then counting homomorphisms 2h
remains easy even if you have to wait in
functions they're not important that you
can deal with those that are not it um
you can even imagine probably even in
the context to the talk is very easy to
deal with that um the next thing is a
little bit interesting suppose that H is
not a start another thing it might be is
you know a caterpillar graph which is
just a graph that looks like a path and
maybe there's some danglies like that so
that's a caterpillar so basically a
caterpillar is a tree that doesn't have
an induced draft that looks like that
and it turns out that for any
caterpillar that's not a star counting
weighted homomorphisms to H is exactly
equivalent to this so that's exactly
what there is on the other hand if H is
not accounted Hillier than it does have
an induced sub graph that looks like
that and already counting homomorphisms
is sad so this is another little world
where we've got a complete understand
we've got FP is sat there's nothing else
okay and then we have to confess if H
stops being a tree even in the weighted
world we've got legs and I've been
problems their stuff we don't understand
that's good because we've got a turn
here maybe some of this will get
resolved ah if you make it unweighted
and you stick to trees it's still not
resolved that sounds strange right tree
should be easy but actually we don't
even understand the complexity for all
trees and the next thing i want to show
you and that may be able to leave the
slide here is that hollow morphisms to
this thing here which is kind of ugly in
the middle of my slide that is the three
spin pots model so if you count
homomorphisms to this graph that's
exactly equivalent in complexity to
computing the partition function of the
ferromagnetic three pots model and if
you would just grow the number of
branches to queue that he would get the
Q state pots models so pots models are
exactly the same as counting on
morphisms to these these graphs which
are just you know stars except for that
you stretched all their edges okay now
interesting that when you root get rid
of the weights we do have trees that are
sat hard but once upon a time we had a
conjecture and we thought that all
counting humble morphisms to trees
without weights would always be in this
but that turns out to be false so we
know trees we're counting homomorphisms
approximately to them is sat heart and
one of them is based on taking
thoughts model graph and then just
decorating it with some trees that hang
off it and that'll give you an example
that's hard so I I suspect that trees
probably can be classified but we but we
well we don't have that yet and anyway
there's deep problems inside it because
the bus modal verbs them so you'd have
to resolve the box model ferromagnetic
box model in order to classify him off
it looks to trace pardon my Louis in
this area what is so special about this
James McGraw that leads to the
separation immediately it hasn't induced
it is in scientific cosmic message okay
so the question is how come this one is
so much harder than the other um I'm
never very good at answering these
questions because if they do I would be
tempted to say it just is but let me try
to do a little better than that um if
you have a caterpillar graph it's kind
of just linear right oh man this is very
but now you probably said yeah I can
tell that but in a way that gives you a
way of doing the counting right because
it you can imagine that you might almost
be able to use them you could hack up
algorithms based on the linear structure
as soon as you put this this three-way
junction inside I mean can I just say
them we can make gadgets so that it's
hard that's not a very good answer but I
think it's maybe the best second date
not these ones have with war so suggests
that there is an algorithm
justice crew there is yeah there is but
that's precisely the path with one yes
okay some are missing by the way that's
path with one and that's also true if
that's if that makes it more playful I
mean there is an algorithm like that I
just don't know so the j-3 is the graph
you're talking about there and then and
then that could be in the most difficult
it could but then you'd be showing that
approximately the partition functions of
pots model is the most difficult so the
one that don't know which we don't know
actually we know that it's a minimal and
come to that well we know that it's bit
hard but we don't know that it's as hard
as SAT and the one that we do know is
difficult looks like j-3 except for that
there's a whole lot of nonsense that
hangs off of each of these branches to
make the proof go through so whether the
pots model itself is one of those
difficult the symmetry makes it very
hard to deal with so it might be easier
than sad but that's another problem I
mean maybe my picture wasn't very good
but the point of these three blobs is
they look quite different yeah from each
other from each other yeah
okay connection to the pots model and
just did that now what approximate
counting problems are equal to this I'm
not going to spend ages on them I just
want you to give you some kind of a
flavor of what kind of stuff do we know
is equivalent to this okay well counting
down sets in a partial order that's an
important one because it's kind of
canonical so I think you probably know
what a partial order is right just think
of it as a graph where they're just
pulling downwards what's it down said it
just means you know if this vertex is
the end then so is everything below it
so that's that's equivalent to piss
we've we've seen if you graph on the
wharf ISM counting problems and if you
want to know hundreds more formal
morphisms problems that are equivalent
to this Steven Calkins old PhD thesis
about that one to fill one line there's
a lot of counting constraint
satisfaction problems of dave is going
to really pick up on this so i don't
want to tell you about them now I'm but
I want to pick up on a few other
problems and actually um talk about
where diverse stuff turns out to be
equivalent so I don't want to spend very
long County talking about stable
matchings though this may be connects us
to the other seminar here because I
don't see Dan gosfield who's on the
other program here has a lot of work
about the politics the stable matching
problem and that's very relevant to the
proof that so you remember counting
single matchings from teaching
algorithms yeah so you have the men on
one side and the women on one side and
every man has a ranking of all the women
and every woman has a ranking of all the
men
and then you have to find a stable
matching which means that there isn't a
care that would rather than with each
other than with it that matching and so
it turns out that counting stable
matching is in general is a good look to
this but also if you go to various
geometric preference model so you kind
of them you get these rankings from
various Joe I'm not going to tell you
about it but anyway that turns out to be
equivalent and more relevant to this
workshop the the partition function of
the ferromagnetic easing model well we
know from jerem sinclair that that's a
frazzle but if you make the problem just
a little bit harder it becomes
equivalent to this so i want to talk
about two ways you can do that one you
might add mixed fields so i just want to
make sure everybody remember so the
ferromagnetic using model that's the
pots model but with choose bins so
what's a configuration every spin every
vertex of your graph gets either spin
zero or spin one what's the way if two
adjacent vertices have the same spin its
weight 1 plus gamma otherwise we want
okay now jerem Sinclair ferromagnetic
gammas bigger than 0 so vertices liked
me to sing as their neighbors jerem
Sinclair and then probably a 9 thara
nagana probably tell us about this they
give an algorithm for f housing that
partition function um how to make it
this hard suppose that vertices had what
are called external fields which are a
bit like the waiting is in the tree
homomorphism so this vertex prefers to
be sin 0 and whenever it is you can a
little weight for that this other vertex
prefers to be spin 1 and whatever it is
to get a little weight for that if you
have those kind of external weights than
the problem that comes up
what abyss and I decided not to tell you
about that because one way to see the
pretty blue father from the CSP results
that day will tell you about um but what
I do want to tell you a little bit about
there's a ferromagnetic using model on a
hypergraph and there you don't need any
fields at all you just generalize that
is a model too hyper graph and suddenly
instead of becoming if possible it
becomes a critical to this so I
presumably not as possible okay and I
decided on I just kind of jealous of
Ginny because he was telling us such
interesting things and you'll notice I
haven't really told you any proofs at
all yet and I should have done but now I
will and so I'm gonna I'm going to talk
a little bit about the ferromagnetic
using model of a high program because
it's actually quite quite easy to see
that it's equivalent to this so i'm
going to show you that and that maybe
will give you a feel for what is this
biz about and why are some things
equipment and others not but to do it
i'm going to cheat a little bit so i'm
going to use the fact that counting down
steps in a partial order because that
that's really a canonical thing it
really if it feels a lot like this and
so um to go two directions i'm just
going to use that okay if you want to
know i'll tell you about that later okay
so ferromagnetic using model of a
hypergraph well it's a lot what you'd
expect so we've got a hydrograph
hypergraph is just vertices and then
some sense of them which are high
cottages we've got an interaction
strength saying this before gamma what
are configurations well every vertex
gets a spins the rover one exactly like
in the easing model ferromagnetic so
gamma is greater than zero exactly let
the easy model what is the weight of the
configuration same as before except for
we have to say what it means on a hyper
edge so if all the spins are the same on
a hyper edge week
gamma otherwise we give it away one okay
so hyper just have to be monochromatic
all right everyone with that because I'm
going to just give you in the ten
minutes yeah i'll give you just quickly
the proof that it's equivalent to this
brush okay all right ah yes but i forgot
i have to tell you one fat but this is
this is good because now you'll finally
know why i wrote these gammas in such an
obscure way because you might have
wondered why i prefer to always have to
add one and the reason is if you haven't
seen this that there's a lovely
connection which goes back to the
seventies which shows that the partition
function on the easing model i'm
presenting it here for a hypergraph
because that's what i want to use that i
guess they were originally interested in
grass um this is exactly the same as
another partition function which is this
is on top of the top polynomial version
or the random flustered formulation and
I'm just going to tell you what it is
that it suppose that I have a hypergraph
H and I have an interaction gamma what
is this function it's the sum over all
subsets f of edges so just take some of
the hyper edges go back of what well you
get a gamma for every hyper edge that
you put in it and you give it factor of
2 for every connected component what's a
connected component well just own are
many definitions of connected component
in hyper graph but the one that I'm
using is equivalent to saying just
pretend all my bridges work leaks and
then I will be connected
it's either in the graph okay okay no
one for joining castle and do is that
they um they show the do these two
things that these two are exactly to say
and I'm gonna give you it's actually
really it's it's really lovely and
important but it's actually quite easy
to see so let me just don't let me just
give you a hint about how you would see
that and that is that you could look at
the formal song which is the sum over
all configurations that map spins to the
vertices and the sum of the raw edges
and the product overall it's like the
sum over all subsets f edges hyper edges
the product overall little F sub hype
images in your f of this quantity and
now it's I'm not going to do it because
I want to get to I want to get to my
point but if you just process this it's
very easy to see that it's easy to look
for those things so so that gives you
the connection between these two
formulations okay but what do I want to
do I want to show you that this thing is
exactly equivalent to complexity the
biss big surprise i'm going to use one
formulation to go one direction and the
other to go the other that's why should
you both of them okay okay so how do we
see that counting the partition function
of the ferromagnetic using model a
hypergraph how do we see that it's best
hard this is the whole proof so don't
worry it's not going to be complicated
so let i'm going to show you how do you
see that it's this hard so to do that
this is going to be an encouraging the
whole proof by example and this is going
to be a little graph and let's pretend
we wanted to count approximately
independent sets in this graph okay
that's our goal and I'm gonna count
independent sets in this graph and so
for a minute I just want to
think about so I've labeled the vertices
a B C on the left and red blue green on
the right and I want to think about how
many independent sets in this graph is
the right hand side exactly right away
so how many how many independent set is
this the projection onto the right hand
side ok follow the answer be well for
everything on the left hand side I can
put it in or out except for that into
the neighborhood f it has to be out so I
know it's always tempting to just jump
ahead and maybe you guys are all done
but what I want you to know so far I'd
like you two to tell me if you don't see
that yeah so I've got give your little
graph and I want to say how many
independent sets are there where this is
the right hand side and I've just made a
small observation it's that is everyone
good with that ok I know all i'm going
to do is show that i guess the same
formula from the easy model so what am I
going to do I'm going to construct an
instance of the ferromagnetic easy model
on hydrograph how am i construct the
instance well my vertices are going to
be the left hand side ABCDE plus one new
vertex which I'll just throw in be what
are the high bridges well Freddy
verdicts on the right side all that I
bridge so I've got red sole do ABC but I
had feet I've got blue so I do his
neighbors c and d but I have V so for
everything on the right i just gave his
neighborhood pleasantly those are the
hyper edges ok all right and now all I'm
going to do is look at the partition
function of the using model on this
hyper graph I'm going to choose the
interaction energy to the 1 gamma 1 so
you get wait to if you're in
one if you're not that is not important
because you can always stretch a [ __ ]
around and change that if you don't want
that know what that means it does it
means you can make gadgets as serious
parallel graphs that simulated so it's
not important that we chose one that's
what we're going to do for now but what
I want to convince you and it'll be easy
is that if you look at the random
cluster formulation and if we look so
what is it what is the random question
formulation of the partition function
it's the Sun over subsets of Viper edges
of 2 to the number of connected
components there's an interaction here
but because it's one advantages um I'm
going to convince you that it looks very
similar to that so what is the
contribution of F to this sum well it's
two to the number of connected
components how many connected components
either well I've got u plus 1 vertices
but anything that was a neighbor of s
they're all in the same connected
component then just compare these two
things then you see the same up to a
factor of two so if I could count the
easy partition function i have done this
ok ok so i need to stop i think the last
thing i will say is that the reduction
the other way to down sets is actually
completely trivial so if you wanted to
show that you could compute the
partition function of an easing of hyper
graph using down sets all you would do
you use this formulation and you take
each hyper edge and you build the down
set by adding a vertex below and a
vertex above gosh what if these were all
spin one and the down said that has to
be one so I collect two possibilities
what if they were all 0 in the down set
this has to be zero benefit too
possibilities that are to put if there
anything else the ones force 10 is 40 in
this white one so again it's a very
direct connection okay so that's a
that's probably where I need to stop
because I think i'm at a time who knows
i was going to put it back to a sensible
place but i think i wouldn't bother with
that but that we've what we've seen is
that there are a whole lot of things
equivalent to this we got a bunch of
things that are equivalent to SAT like
any NP complete problem counting
independent sets in a graph and so on we
can prove that no homomorphism problems
with biloba so they're all if they're
not trivial their best hard we've got a
whole lot of candidates between this and
SAT like counting colorings of bipartite
graphs County homomorphisms to this
thing and there's a whole lot left to
understand okay
every question is there a mapping
between one of these izing type problems
and kind of like periodically tap in I
probably saw in the last time because in
these stat mech models there is a
duality between like the Ising model and
prefer me on okay so the question is
connection to fatty ins and things like
that one one important thing here is
because I've been in ferromagnetic I've
always got non-negative numbers and so
we don't get the translation but you
could think of some translations like so
for example I don't know if this is what
you're asking them suppose you take the
easing model okay and then you go back
to German Sinclair's algorithm which
does it by translating to even sub
graphs that translation is exactly one
of these holographic I mean another way
exactly another way to say it is that
you apply these holographic
transformation so that said does that
always saw in the last talk was a
polynomial time algorithm for computing
that partition function and I would
guess that like these protection
functions are actually just equal a
little I didn't like the stat mech
models you get an equality of perdition
ose but these Lee I mean these ones we
can't compute exactly you know that okay
so it so they are different is that just
like a feature of how you define guys
model like if i did it with like e to
the minus then leg assigned as a [ __ ]
defenses are actually harder to look
right right there yeah so it's so i
should have maybe said that so even in
the ferromagnetic world if your desire
was to compute the thing exactly
actually becomes its number be hard and
that's not that's not because i didn't
express it in the physics way with the
kind of exponent and putting things
above that's just because it is actually
harder to compute so it's not it's yep
it is harder than just it's not going to
exact all the
turn out well in lesbians opinion we are
looking at all graphs here rather than
just planar graphs they see their
difficulties
so can you just briefly comment if you
changed in your definition from the
approximate easy to democracy other your
dimension but I know and I forgot well I
didn't forget but i don't know i was
designing yeah i didn't get to it and I
promised you say thank you so over here
it was asked about the log partition
function and I said I would come back to
it and I didn't now a very interesting
thing is if you would for example count
satisfying assignments that's a very
hard problem and even if you would
approximate the lock that's hard so
counting even the log of the number of
satisfying assignments it's what we know
if you could approximate that then you
would be solving it and be hard problem
however these AP reductions don't
preserve approximation of the log and
for a lot of these hard problems we
don't know so for example something
we're very interested in is
approximating the log of abyss in fact
we've already worked a lot on this
without much success and please everyone
all such I mean it's a really
interesting thing to know whether you
could do that your nose and I don't know
but we don't know it yeah and and these
reductions are the wrong tool as well
for that so but I mean there are other
tools but the main thing is that like
yeah so for example counting independent
sets in planar graphs this is varying a
little bit off so i'll show that quite
quickly but let's i think everybody
knows about the hard core model where
you're counting independent sets but
with weights and if you make the wait be
enough then you get to where you can
approximate the log in planar so i'm
just saying that the think some things
are actually easier and so we don't get
this beautiful connection that we get
with partition functions and there's a
really fascinating area to explore and
not much is known about it yeah
questions so so suppose that was an AP
reduction from upper sides to remember
this do we have any sort of unlikely
complexity there a big consequences of
that okay excellent so the question was
what if we could show that this was the
scientist at would there be any
consequences and um well no maybe where
I mean it's always possible we're
building a house of cards and they can
come tumbling down and it doesn't as far
as I know have any consequences like for
decision complexity or anything else the
only thing I'd say is that you know in
2003 here's something it seemed quite
plausible that it wasn't anything real
it was just about proof techniques but
more and more of these problems as we do
get places where there are these try
colonies like tend to believe now it
means something but yeah there's no
barrier this could be San hard and could
just be that we're too stupid to think
of the reduction and if you think of one
that would be to the excellent bit
unlikely yeah I mean everything is going
on flawless with an empty after trying
some gradation within an opinion such a
dog but we don't know anything well
that's why I think this is interested in
discussing this like is in pier with NP
complete there is definitely information
you don't miss me
anyone question let's thank twist again